en travaillant écrire un texte qui se
développe ta pensée exactement
entre professeur ces jours-ci Marianne
Théberge doit composer avec cette
nouvelle réalité elle est convaincue que
certains de ses étudiants ont utilisé
l'intelligence artificielle pour écrire
leurs travaux
c'est la consigne dans le cas de plagiat
de manière générale ça prend des preuves
mais c'est difficile d'avoir une preuve
absolument claire des outils de
détection de l'intelligence artificielle
qui utilise eux-mêmes l'intelligence
artificielle existe mais ils sont loin
d'être infaillibles ils ne sont pas
suffisants pour démontrer et sanctionner
la tricherie j'ai pas l'impression que
j'ai eu beaucoup de copies
qui ont eu recours j'ai fait des
avertissements sérieux mais c'est un peu
utile mettre un place un sur une
hémorragie là pour rassurer et guider
les professeurs à l'université de
céréales le règlement sur le plagiat a
été modifié les formations ont été mises
sur pied et un guide de bonnes pratiques
dans des cotes soupçons de plagiat a été
envoyée aux enseignants de certaines
facultés il faut changer nos évaluations
les évaluations de type traditionnelle
dissertation travail à la maison doivent
être beaucoup plus encadrés ça veut pas
dire qu'on les enlève ça veut dire qu'il
faut modifier notre façon d'enseigner à
la suite du dépôt d'un rapport interne
le plus important syndicat d'enseignants
au cégep et de chargés de cours à
l'université revendique maintenant un
moratoire d'urgence sur le développement
des systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
c'est utilisation tous azimute elle doit
être balisée donc il faut pour l'instant
là et prendre un peu de recul et prendre
au sérieux les impacts que
l'intelligence artificielle peut avoir
Québec n'a pas encore pris position sur
un éventuel encadrement de
l'intelligence artificielle mais une
journée de réflexion se tiendra demain à
Montréal et plus de 900 acteurs du
milieu de l'enseignement supérieur il
Macron dans la ministre Pascal Derry je
pense que c'est une bonne chose qu'on
ait une réflexion de manière générale et
qu'on puisse se pencher là-dessus pour
que justement éventuellement on puisse
voir un peu comment est-ce qu'on peut
intervenir si on doit intervenir de
quelle manière on doit intervenir chose
certaine bien des enseignants sont
impatients et espèrent plus de soutien
et d'outils pour les aider à s'adapter
il faut d'abord avant tout prendre ce
problème-là bravo le corps puis que ça
soit sur la place publique ici Fanny
Bussière Montréal